[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est Paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux l'image de cet été 2023 l'image
de ce Paléo news c'est évidemment aussi
l'homme de glace enfin l'homme des
glaces découvert en Italie en 1991 dans
les Alpes et datées de 5000 ans aussi je
vous remontre la photo de la momie ici
pour que vous le voyez
a désormais un nouveau visage donc voilà
à quoi on pensait qu'il ressemblait
depuis sa découverte et voilà le nouveau
visage d'otsi un beau visage foncé avec
une calvitie plutôt prononcée alors ça
c'est le résultat des analyses
génétiques récentes dont on va parler
dans une minute mais juste avant ça je
voudrais sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
une telle panique identitaire c'était
délicieux c'était jouissif un vrai
défilé de la SS dans les commentaires
[Rires]
[Musique]
donc voilà c'est tellement beau c'est
tellement beau de voir la science
progressée et puis les obscurantistes
s'accrocher comme ça à leurs rêves d'une
race européenne pure quoi c'est juste
c'est juste hilarant alors c'est quoi la
science derrière cette nouvelle
reconstitution d'Otis ce visage foncé et
cette calvitie naissance et bien c'est
un article publié dans la revue
prestigieuse celle génomix par des
paléogénéticiens qui ont donc ré-analysé
ré-analyser l'ADN de hotsi alors on
avait déjà analysé l'ADN de hotsi il y a
un moment mais c'était il y a très
longtemps c'était en 2012 d'ailleurs et
donc depuis 2012 en fait la technologie
a tellement évolué c'est de la folie
c'est de faut voir que pour atteindre le
premier génome de Néandertal en 2010 il
y avait fallu des équipes du monde
entier qui ont travaillé pendant 10 ans
je crois un truc comme ça ça c'était en
2010 maintenant pour séquencer le génome
d'année andertal il suffit un peu de
poudre de mettre ça dans un tube
t'attends une heure et pouf c'est fait
bon j'exagère mais j'exagère mais en
fait ce que ce qui avait pris le monde
entier toute l'expertise paléogénétique
du monde et plus de 10 ans en 2010 enfin
entre 2000 et 2010 du coup aujourd'hui
ça se fait en a claquement de doigts on
a une telle connaissance des techniques
maintenant la technique a tellement
progressé que ça se fait vachement mieux
et donc ils ont du coup réanalysé la
momie de hoty parce que c'était vraiment
un des premiers trucs on s'est dit mais
ça il faut qu'on analyse son ADN quoi
donc ça a été fait en 2012 et ça a été
refait donc plus récemment et ils ont
découvert de nouveaux résultats et
notamment le résultat le plus
intéressant et qu'il mette en lumière
dès le début dès l'introduction de
l'article c'est il y a de l'ADN de
chasseurs-cueilleurs dans le dans le
génome de hotsi et ça c'est très
intéressant parce que aussi il a vécu il
y a donc 5000 ans à 5000 ans c'est déjà
le début du tout tout début du
néolithique
c'est déjà la première migration des
fermiers en fait c'est à dire des
agriculteurs venus du Moyen-Orient et
qui vont migrer en Europe pour apporter
l'agriculture et hotsine normalement
devait faire partie de ces gens-là et là
on découvre qu'il a quand même de l'ADN
finalement de chasseur cueilleurs alors
très peu c'est vraiment très très peu
d'ADN mais du coup ils ont à réussi à
dater l'événement d'hybridation et donc
c'est 56 générations à plus ou moins une
vingtaine de générations près de
l'époque à laquelle a vécu aussi donc à
peu près 5000 ans avant Jésus-Christ
pour cet événement d'hybridation 5000
ans avant Jésus-Christ c'est c'est quand
même pas c'est du coup à peu près 2000
ans avant aussi quoi donc ça permet de
mieux dater en fait ces événements de
migration qui ont eu lieu donc notamment
la migration des de ces peuples du
Moyen-Orient en direction d'Europe donc
ça c'est l'une des nouvelles les plus
intéressantes de cet article sur la PA
alors ils ont pas analysé que au tir ils
ont analysé plein d'autres génomes venus
d'Europe évidemment c'est pas que aussi
et donc ils ont découvert vous voyez
cette partie en vert là ce sont les
chasseurs-cueilleurs et cette partie en
orange ici dans le génome de hotsi c'est
la partie qu'ils appellent anatolienne
de son génome donc l'Anatolie c'est la
Turquie donc c'est finalement le génome
des fermiers des agriculteurs qui
étaient qui ont migré en Europe et ont
amené la révolution néolithique avec eux
donc le le
ice man donc hotsi l'homme de glace a
une grande partie de son génome qui est
anatolien plus de 95% de son génome et
Anatolia et de ce fait ressemble
beaucoup aux Italiens locaux au final
donc c'est une en fait ce qu'on regarde
avec aussi c'est un individu issu d'une
immigration très récente
une immigration de des néolithiques des
gens du néolithique des gens de la
culture néolithique en Europe qui est
relativement récente ils ont encore une
très forte signature anatolienne dans
leur génome et ça c'est intéressant pour
comprendre les migrations
donc la panique la fameuse panique
identitaire évidemment il nous disent ah
mais vous aussi il avait le même génome
que les Sardes il n'était pas du tout
noir et oui mais les
Sardes c'est pas les Sardes de les c'est
pas les stars de maintenant dont on
parle c'est pas les gens qui habitent en
Sardaigne maintenant qui ont été
analysés assez bien les gens qui
habitaient en Sardaigne à l'époque c'est
bien le génome des gens de l'époque
d'ailleurs c'est très très clairement
figuré ici vous voyez là les Sardes ici
sont représentés avec une étoile cette
étoile veut dire les individus
contemporains de hotsi donc il y avait
pas de secret il y avait pas de il y a
rien qui a été dissimulé dans cette
histoire
donc c'est assez fou de voir à quel
point les gens ne veulent juste pas
entendre la vérité oui les Européens
étaient noirs à la base et donc c'est le
c'est le paragraphe suivant ils ont
utilisé les marqueurs génétiques de la
pigmentation donc il y a plusieurs il y
a des centaines de marqueurs là ils en
ont analysé d'ailleurs je crois plus de
170 ouais c'est ça donc plus de 170
marqueurs de la pigmentation de la peau
et donc ça permet d'obtenir alors si ça
permet pas de dire exactement de quelle
couleur il était ça permet au moins
d'obtenir un certain pourcentage
pourcentage de confiance en une et à la
limite si vous voulez une genre de
palette de couleur au moins relative
donc c'est vraiment un degré en fait de
pigmentation de la peau ou de
probabilité on va dire c'est même plus
que ça c'est un degré de probabilité de
pigmentation de la peau qu'on obtient en
faisant ce genre d'analyse et en
analysant du coup c'est ces marqueurs
génétiques de la pigmentation bah il
trouve que du coup il avait la peau
foncée plus foncé que les populations de
Sardaigne d'aujourd'hui donc c'est ce
qui est dit là dans ce paragraphe enfin
dans ce cette phrase ici
mise en jaune donc il avait la peau plus
foncée que les populations de Sardaigne
d'aujourd'hui mais par contre moins
foncée que les chasseurs-cueilleurs qui
vivaient avant lui les fameux
chasseurs-cueilleurs avec qui ces
ancêtres se sont hybridés 56 générations
plutôt donc c'est c'est cette migration
anatolienne qui a amené finalement la
première éclaircissement de la peau
éclaircissement de la peau qui va
continuer au fur et à mesure que de
nouvelles migrations vont arriver depuis
l'Europe de l'Est vers l'Europe de
l'Ouest parce que l'histoire de l'Europe
c'est ça c'est des migrations de
population eurasiatique de l'Est qui
migre vers l'Ouest et en nous confirme
bien par la génétique la chronologie des
arrivées des populations des steps
puisque
OTSI n'a aucune
n'a aucun lien de parenté avec les
populations des steppes les fameuses
populations des steppes qui arriveront
d'Europe de l'Est plus tard donc
aussi était vraiment dans cette
transition en fait dans le degré
d'éclaircissement de la peau finalement
et et là où c'est très marrant en fait
de constater cette cette panique cette
panique identitaire c'est que hey les
gars la momie la momie vous vous
rappelez aussi c'est une momie à la base
la momie elle ressemble à ça
c'est à dire que il y a quand même des
gens qui sont allés me dire que c'était
de la mauvaise science de dire que aussi
était noir et que c'était wok et que et
que quand même vous exagérez parce que
bon voilà c'est du c'est du blackwashing
ou je sais pas quoi eh les mecs la momie
elle est brune moi je veux pas dire elle
est noire parce que mais elle est brune
la momie elle est brune il y a des
mélanosomes dans la peau de la momie
d'ailleurs il le rappelle très bien dans
l'article il y a des mélanosomes enfin
il y a de la mélanine dans la peau de la
momie donc je sais pas d'où vous sortez
cette panique morale à l'époque de la
découverte je me rappelle justement
c'était un problème que aussi soit si
foncé en fait c'est à l'époque ils
avaient justement sorti d'un peu nulle
part que c'était les les dommages dû à
la tafonomie qui avait rendu la momie
brune et ils avaient donc ils avaient
brodé toute une histoire autour du fait
que oui alors
on dit que aussi il est blanc parce que
en fait la peau brune c'est juste dû à
la décomposition machin tout ça non la
peau brune c'était dû à la présence de
mélanine parce que aussi il avait pas il
avait la peau brune je veux dire la
momie est brune bon sang
et c'est à l'époque qu'on avait inventé
une histoire pour expliquer pourquoi la
momie était brune alors qu'on
s'imaginait qu'il était qu'il était
blanc
cette présence de mélanine se reflète
dans les marqueurs génétiques de la
couleur de la peau qu'ils ont analysé
contrairement aux analyses précédentes
autre si aussi alors il parle pas de
cette histoire d'assassinat si vous avez
entendu parler de hotsi il y a toute une
histoire autour du fait que aussi était
un peu a été chassé jusqu'à sa mort il a
été obligé de se réfugier tout en haut
des Alpes pour échapper à des
poursuivants qui l'ont tué ou du moins
c'est la c'est le scénario qui a été
reconstruit pour pour rendre compte du
fait qu'il soit mort aussi loin de chez
lui bon il a pas fui depuis l'Anatolie
comme je dis ils étaient déjà installés
depuis une cinquantaine de générations
apparemment mais voilà apparemment
c'était un paria quoi et il a des
blessures effectivement il y a un autre
truc avec la reconstitution qu'ils ont
fait là le haut-disant il a aucun
tatouage alors que Audi il est couvert
de tatouages enfin il est pas couvert de
tatouages mais il a plein de tatouages
sur lui donc c'est pareil cette
reconstitution là
il y a beaucoup plus d'erreurs du à
l'idéologie que sur celle-ci
[Musique]
bref c'est pas parce que la mode
aujourd'hui est à pointer tout ce qui
est wok que ça veut dire que tout ce qui
ressemble à du wok et forcément du wok
bref
donc voilà d'où ça sort cette histoire
de hozzi et à la peau brune et la
calvitie bah pareil il y a des marqueurs
génétiques de la calvitie et donc pareil
probabilité Audi a une très forte
probabilité d'avoir une calvitie
naissante surtout que je crois qu'il
avait entre 40 et 50 ans un truc comme
ça donc oui c'est pour ça qu'il est
chauve sur cette nouvelle reconstitution
voilà toute la vérité sur ce nouvel
article dans paru dans celle génomix à
propos de hotsi on continue avec de la
paléogénétique et cette fois un article
qui va s'intéresser alors uniquement à
la génétique des êtres humains modernes
il n'y a pas de fossiles qui ont été
utilisés dans cette étude là mais ils
ont quand même réussi grâce à dans cette
étude à étudier la démographie du passé
et ça c'est super intéressant à étudier
la démographie du passé parce que ça
permet de voir notamment s'il y a eu des
événements de goulet d'étranglement ce
qu'on appelle des bottle neck en anglais
alors comment est-ce qu'on étudie la
démographie du passé en regardant le
génome de Homo sapiens moderne de toutes
les populations d'Homo sapiens modernes
c'est relativement intuitif en fait on
va regarder la diversité de génétique
donc on va prendre un gène et on va
regarder la diversité de ce gène en
fonction des populations à travers le
monde et cette diversité génétique en
fait va être le reflet de ce qui a pu
être hérité d'une population ancestrale
donc plus vous auriez eu une population
orcestrale
diversifiée en termes génétique pour un
gène donné plus cette plus cette
population sera grande une grande
population amène plus une plus grande
diversité le on va dire l'hypothèse de
base étant qu'une grande population a
une plus grande diversité
et à l'inverse si un gène a très très
peu de diversité génétiques vous avez
peu de mutation vous avez peu d'ailes et
bien on peut faire l'hypothèse que
l'ancêtre en commun c'était une petite
population avec une diversité génétique
assez réduite vous répétez ça avec plein
de Gênes qui évoluent à différentes
vitesses et vous pouvez reconstituer
finalement la démographie de population
à travers le temps sur toute notre
lignée qui a mené à Homo sapiens ce
moderne donc un gène qui évolue très
lentement
produira une diversité génétique qui
pourra être datée de très très loin dans
le temps alors qu'un gène qui évolue
rapidement produira une diversité
génétique qui pourra être datée de
relativement proche de nous dans le
temps et en faisant ça et alors ça
demande ça demande une quantité de
connaissances que je n'ai pas ça demande
une quantité de compétences que je n'ai
pas mais en gros il y a des modèles qui
sont utilisés des modèles informatiques
pour calculer toutes ces distances
génétiques pour calculer toutes ces taux
de mutation pour calculer quand ces
ancêtres hypothétiques ont vécu et donc
là ce qu'ils ont fait dans ce nouvel
article c'est qu'ils ont proposé un
nouveau modèle qui s'appelle le fitcool
donc c'est un nouveau programme qui
permet de reconstituer des la
démographie du passé en fonction de la
de la de la diversité génomique de Homo
sapiens modernes et ce faisant ce qu'ils
ont remarqué et bien c'est un
crash en termes de population effective
alors la population effective c'est la
population de reproducteurs pourquoi on
précise une population de couples
reproducteurs tout simplement parce
qu'on regarde la génétique de leur
descendants à ces populations ancestrale
et donc si ils ont eu des descendants
c'est qu'ils ont été reproducteurs on ne
peut pas s'intéresser à la génétique de
gens qui n'ont eu aucun descendant
puisque bah ils ont pas laissé de
descendre donc on n'a pas accès aux
données
donc ils ont constaté un crash en termes
de taille de population qui a eu lieu à
peu près il y a un million d'années donc
un million d'années ça nous ramène ça
nous ramène plus ou moins à Homo erectus
en Afrique
en Afrique on est on a Homo erectus qui
évolue oui c'est ça à peu près il y a
1,8 millions d'années 2 millions
d'années
et qui se répand dans tout le dans
toutes leurs Asie il y a 1,8 millions
d'années voire même un peu plus que ça
bref mais Homo erectus il va rester là
pendant un moment avant que l'espèce
suivante qui est le pré-homo sapiens
sport qu'on appelle edelbergen 6 parfois
edelbergens qui va apparaître entre 600
000 et 400 000 ans en gros donc un
million d'années en Afrique on est sur
Homo erectus et d'ailleurs à peu près
partout dans le monde on est sur Homo
erectus de toute façon
donc on a crash de population au niveau
de Homo erectus reconstitué grâce à la
génétique de Homo sapiens modernes la
belle diversité génétique de tous les
Homo sapiens modernes et ça nous ça
pointe du doigt une population qui a
chuté jusqu'à une population qu'ils
estiment à
120 individus 1280 individus
reproducteurs ça veut pas dire qu'ils
étaient que 1280 mais 1280 individus
reproducteur
total dans le monde c'est un truc de fou
c'est 1280 individus total dans le monde
qui sont les ancêtres d'après leur
modèle qui sont les ancêtres de la
totalité d'Homo sapiens modernes alors
déjà à signaler c'est pas dans le monde
en réalité c'est que en Afrique parce
qu'en fait ce
cet événement se goulet d'étranglement
parce que là on parle vraiment d'un
goulet d'étranglement quand on a une
réduction drastique de la population
vous voyez c'est vraiment ce qui est
représenté là vous avez une population
de presque 100 000 individus
reproducteurs et ici vous avez ce goulet
d'étranglement avant que la population
remonte ici à 30000 individus à peu près
il y a 800 000 ans
donc c'est ça le goulet d'étranglement
dont il parle 1280 individus mais c'est
pas 1280 individus répartis dans le
monde entier en réalité il ne trouve de
signe de ce goulet d'étranglement que en
Afrique
donc il y a que les populations
africaines qui qui préservent finalement
ce des traces génétiques de ce goulet
d'étranglement la raison pour ça c'est
que tout simplement l'Afrique la majeure
partie de la diversité génétique d'Homo
sapiens se trouve en Afrique ça on le
sait déjà
90% de notre diversité génétique vient
d'Afrique et on sait que les le reste du
monde n'a été peuplé que par un autre
goulet d'étranglement en réalité il y a
eu un une toute petite fraction de cette
population africaine qui est sorti
d'Afrique pour aller peupler le reste du
monde
et du coup ça veut dire que les
marqueurs génétiques de ce goulet
d'étranglement ont été perdus les gens
qui portaient ce marqueur les marqueurs
génétiques de ce goulet d'étranglement
finalement on finit par mourir sans
descendant et ça ça vous illustre en
fait une des faiblesses de ce genre de
reconstruction c'est qu'en fait on ne
peut travailler que avec les gènes qui
ont survécu chez les gens qui vivent
aujourd'hui
on a accès que à cette diversité là si
il y a des marqueurs génétiques qui ont
été perdus complètement et donc s'il y a
des branches entières de notre de notre
généalogie qui ont qui sont restés sans
descendance il y a forcément une grande
part de notre diversité génétique
actuelle qui a été perdue et de fait on
perd finalement l'accès à cette
population ancestrale si une population
ancestrale a donné des descendants mais
que ses descendants 100 000 ans plus
tard
ce sont tous éteints on n'aura pas accès
à cette diversité là et du coup on va
sous-estimer le nombre d'individus de la
population ancestrale qui a donné tout
Homo sapiens moderne donc là
1800 individus reproducteurs d'après ce
qui est préservé dans le génome actuel
cette population a de toute façon été
plus grande puisque il y avait aussi des
individus non reproducteurs
mais cette population elle peut aussi
avoir été avoir été plus grande
simplement parce qu'il y a des branches
entières de notre arbre évolutif enfin
de notre arbre généalogique qui ont
complètement disparu qui de fait n'ont
pas laissé de trace permettant de
reconstituer leur contribution à cette
population ancestrale donc à relativiser
mais ça reste non moins un chiffre assez
effrayant parce que parce que parce que
1200 individus c'est comme ils le disent
d'ailleurs dans l'article c'est c'est
une espèce en danger critique
d'extinction donc même si on est même
s'il y avait 10 000 individus en réalité
on est quand même sur une espèce qui est
en danger d'extinction quoi c'est très
très peu même s'ils se sont loupés d'un
facteur d'un facteur 10 donc il y aurait
plus de 12000 individus en réalité ça
reste une population en danger
d'extinction
surtout répartis sur un continent entier
comme l'Afrique donc c'est vraiment une
découverte qui est assez intéressante et
si elle se confirme évidemment il y a
que leur modèle pour l'instant qui a
trouvé ça parce que avant les autres
modèles n'ont pas retrouvé ce cet
événement en même temps c'est un
événement qui a eu lieu il y a un
million d'années vous imaginez que dans
notre génome il doit pas être non plus
hyper facile à trouver comment savoir si
cet événement a réellement eu lieu bon
alors il nous parle des fossiles en nous
disant il y a un gap dans le registre
fossile il y a un million d'années alors
oui mais en même temps si vous
recherchez les Gap dans le registre
fossile vous en trouverez un quasiment
tous les 200 vous en trouverez un tous
les 200.000 ans quoi donc trouver un gap
dans le registre fossile c'est pas non
plus hyper compliqué il y en a partout
donc on trouvait un qui coïncide avec un
million d'années enfin 900 000 ans la
comédie
ouais pas impressionné par contre là où
ça devient impressionnant c'est le petit
paragraphe que j'ai que j'ai mis en
jaune ici
ce bottleck arrive au même moment que la
mutation qui a provoqué la fusion de
notre chromosome de ça avec les
chimpanzés ont un chromosome en plus que
nous pourquoi parce que notre chromosome
2 en fait chez le chimpanzé il est
divisé en deux et en fait ces deux
chromosomes se sont fusionnés l'un à
l'autre pour former notre chromosome 2
quelque part pendant l'évolution de nos
ancêtres les Hominines
donc cette fusion de chromosomes c'est
la raison pour laquelle on ne peut plus
se reproduire avec les chimpanzés et
donc biologiquement nous sommes
considérés comme deux espèces séparées
on avait trouvé dans le dans la dans
notre génome et dans celui des
chimpanzés des traces d'hybridation de
nos ancêtres qui avaient eu lieu en 6 et
7 millions d'années je crois voire même
moi je crois même 3 millions d'années
bref il y a eu des trains il y a des
traces d'hybridation qui ont pu avoir
lieu entre nos ancêtres à nous et les
ancêtres des chimpanzés modernes qui ont
eu lieu si je me rappelle bien entre 3
et 6 millions d'années peu importe la
date ce qui importe c'est que à un
million d'années en fait la fusion de
ces deux chromosomes elle est datée par
horloge moléculaire de 1 million
d'années et du coup ça coïncide à fond
avec cet événement de de réduction
drastique de la taille des populations
d'Homo sapiens et ça c'est très
intéressant parce que justement on
s'imagine bien qu'un événement
chromosomique majeur une mutation
chromosomique majeure comme ça là qui a
résulté en la fusion de deux chromosomes
pour que ça se retrouve aujourd'hui chez
tous les humains modernes ça n'a pu
avoir lieu que pendant un événement de
bottle Nike que pendant un événement de
goulet d'étranglement par laquelle la
population la taille de la population
était très réduite cette mutation
apparaît se répand dans cette petite
population ce qui peut arriver
ce qui se passe quand on a un événement
de de goulet d'étranglement comme ça
c'est qu'en fait la sélection naturelle
la sélection naturelle a des ratés voilà
il y a la sélection naturelle c'est pas
qu'elle marche plus évidemment qu'elle
marche encore mais en gros il y a des
trucs complètement aberrants qui vont
apparaître et qui ne seront pas contre
sélectionnés parce que la population est
trop petite et du coup les gènes se
répandent trop vite donc il y a des
mutations assez catastrophiques comme la
fusion de deux chromosomes qui peuvent
se produire dans des populations
en état de en état de goulet
d'étranglement
et ces mutations vont se rapidement se
répandre dans cette petite population et
ensuite quand la population reprend du
poil de la bête ben en fait cette
mutation catastrophique qui normalement
aurait dû être contre sélectionné dans
un environnement où la diversité
génétique était suffisante pour étouffer
finalement cette mutation dans un dans
une population à faible diversité
génétique cette mutation elle va elle va
exploser et une fois que la population
va se re répandre elle va répandre cette
mutation catastrophique avec elle parce
que cette mutation catastrophique ne
pourra plus être contre sélectionné
parce qu'elle n'aura de toute façon pas
de concurrents il y a pas de concurrence
la diversité génétique est crevée elle
est morte donc il y a rien pour étouffer
cette cette mutation catastrophique
et donc avec la coïncidence de ces deux
événements là on tient quelque chose on
tient une histoire et en l'occurrence
l'histoire contient c'est que bah il y a
eu donc bottle Nike qui a eu goulet
d'étranglement la population devient
minuscule voilà 1000 peu importe
individu
cette population à l'intérieur de cette
population la mutation catastrophique la
fusion des chromosomes a lieu la fusion
des chromosomes qui normalement serait
contre sélectionné dans n'importe quel
autre condition dans un dans une
situation de Bolton Nike elle se fixe
dans la population
et ensuite quand la population d'Homo
sapiens regrandit donc là cet événement
là et bien elle emporte avec elle cette
mutation partout et tous les descendants
de cette population portent cette
mutation et ça inclus d'après ce petit
paragraphe Homo sapiens les Denisova et
les Néandertal tous descendants
voilà et ça je trouve ça complètement de
la folie
si vous êtes très très attaché à la
définition biologique de la spéciation
c'est à dire la capacité de se
reproduire et de donner des individus
fertiles et bien c'est à ce moment-là il
y a un million d'années pendant cet
événement se goulet d'étranglement c'est
à ce moment là que notre espèce s'est
séparé du chimpanzé j'imaginais pas
qu'un jour on pourrait dire c'est là que
ça s'est produit et si ils l'ont fait
ils l'ont fait et ça c'est de la balle
c'est de la balle j'adore faire ces
Paléo news j'adore trouver ces des news
comme ça parce que c'est juste de la
folie furieuse en fait c'est juste un
tout petit paragraphe ils ont à peine
communiqué à propos de ça mais c'est ça
le truc important de cette histoire on
termine sur la Paléo protéomie qu'on a
vu la paléogénétique maintenant on passe
à la Paléo protéomique avec parenthropus
parenthropus notre cousin végétarien
l'australopithèque robuste si vous
connaissez peut-être plus ce nom
australopithèque robuste c'est en fait
un genre à part par entropus qui a vécu
en même temps que les premiers
représentants du genre Homo Homo habilis
entre 1 et 2 millions d'années à peu
près à la louche et qui a vécu
uniquement en Afrique donc par anthropus
il a un petit cerveau mais il a
d'énormes mâchoires il a d'énormes dents
donc c'est ça qui est le différencier
essentiellement des australopithèques et
du genre homo et donc ce parentropus
en Afrique du Sud dans des restes
découverts dans la grotte de Swatch
grants on a réussi à en extraire des
protéines ça y est des protéines
dominées anciens des des restes
fossilisés dominidés anciens des dents
dont on a pu extraire des protéines
en Afrique du Sud et ces protéines ont
permis de reconstituer Mesdames et
Messieurs le premier arbre
phylogénétique de de des
incluant des hominés qui ont vécu il y a
plus d'un million d'années et ça
mesdames et messieurs enfin un arbre
phylogénétique mais basé sur des
séquences d'acides aminés quoi alors
l'occurrence je crois même qu'ils ont
converti les acides aminés en ADN
puisque évidemment les chaque acide
aminé qui composent une protéine de
collagène peut-être rétrocodée en ADN
puisque l'ADN enfin les acides aminés
étant directement codés par les
séquences ADN ça veut dire que si on
connaît les acides aminés on peut on
peut les rétrocoder en ADN donc on a le
premier arbre phylogénétique mesdames et
messieurs
basé sur de l'ADN qui inclut par
anthropus
et ça c'est de la folie furieuse
mesdames et messieurs c'est la folieuse
je le résultat est pas surprenant du
tout on s'affole pas vous voyez vous
avez Homo sapiens de nizovane et
andertal qui forment un Cloud et vous
avez parentropulpuce qui forme un
clavier il y en a un qui se promène un
peu il y a un parenthropus là vous voyez
qui se promène un peu au milieu mais
c'est peut-être dû au fait que la
séquence d'acides aminés c'est mal
préservé mais vous avez mesdames et
messieurs
l'ADN de parents trop puce
imaginez les possibilités imaginez on
peut peut-être un jour on pourra ça ça
ouvre des possibilités de fou ça ouvre
des possibilités d'accéder à à des
séquences d'acides aminés issus du
collagène de d'australopithicules de
homona Lady de de je sais pas moi
imaginer ce que vous voulez pourquoi pas
silenthropus imaginez les possibilités
ça va être de la folie 2 millions
d'années enfin un million d'années alors
en l'occurrence celle de Sword Krantz là
qu'ils ont utilisé elles ont un million
d'années ces séquences un million
d'années il y a encore du collagène
qu'on peut rétrrocoder en ADN c'est de
la folie furieuse c'est de la folie
furieuse qui est en train de se passer
alors c'est pas encore un article publié
pour l'instant c'est un prêt print mais
honnêtement je l'ai lu
j'ai rien trouvé qui m'a choqué alors
peut-être que les paléogénéticiens vont
trouver quelque chose qui les choque
mais moi en tout cas il y a rien qui m'a
choqué et il y a même un truc c'est que
dans le dans l'émail des dents de ces de
ses parents trop puces ils ont réussi à
trouver
une protéine
et cette protéine elle s'appelle Amel y
ou Amel X en l'occurrence donc Amel pour
Naël les mailles et X ou Y en fonction
de si c'est la version mal ou femelle de
cette protéine ce qui veut dire que on
peut s'exer nos parents trop puces on
peut dire à quel sexe s'ils
appartenaient il y a une protéine dans
vos ratisches
moi je savais pas je savais pas il y a
une protéine dans vos ratisches qui
permet de dire si vous avez si vous êtes
double X ou XY c'est ouf c'est ouf et
donc ils ont sexé leurs parents
entreprises grâce à ça alors il y a une
marge d'erreur sur le sexage mais en
gros ce qu'ils ont découvert c'est que
nous un peu bêtement pas les anthologue
que nous sommes quand il y avait des
grosses dents vert on regarde les
gorilles je veux dire on regarde les
gorilles modernes les gorilles modernes
qui ont des énormes denses et les mâles
et les gorilles modernes qui ont des qui
ont des petites danses et les femelles
donc nous qu'est-ce qu'on avait fait
avec nos dents et ben on avait regardé
les grosses c'est des mâles et les
petites dents c'est des femelles surtout
quand là on parle dedans isolées
généralement avec parenthropus on a
quelques crânes ok mais
on a quand même surtout des Ratis isolés
et là où c'est formidable du coup c'est
que maintenant on possède un moyen
indépendant de la taille pour sexer nos
parents trop puces et bah il y a des
petites ratiches qui appartiennent à des
mâles
il y a des petites dents qui
appartiennent à des mâles les articles
qui changent des choses en vrai dans
l'histoire de l'évolution humaine c'est
des articles comme ça parce que là non
seulement on voit s'ouvrir devant nous
une nouvelle univers de possibilités
avec les analyses phylogénétiques et
protéomique philoprotéomique des hominés
qui ont plus d'un million d'années mais
en plus donc en plus de voir ça ce
profilé devant nous on voit devant nous
la possibilité de sexer nos fossiles
imaginez c'est que c'est les fossiles de
façon indépendante à la morphologie
c'est ouf c'est oufissime donc là là on
est peut-être face à quelque chose qui
va réellement faire bouger
ce qu'on sait ou croix savoir de la
paléonthopologie et ça c'est de la balle
ça c'est de la bombe de balle et je on
attend que cet article soit publié parce
qu'il est je le rappelle il n'est pas
encore publié c'est un prêt print donc
on attend qu'il soit publié pour se
réjouir mais
ça ça mesdames et messieurs c'est du bon
avant de continuer petit aparté au money
est-ce que je vais parler de Mona Lady
dans ce Paléo news la réponse est non
puisque les articles ne sont pas encore
publiés donc la science n'est pas encore
publiée n'est pas encore fini par contre
j'ai fait une intervention dont je vais
mettre le lien dans la description chez
Thomas Durand à la tronche en biais où
je parle du documentaire
donc avec Thomas Durand on parle du
documentaire sur
omonaledy qui dans les sens raconte à
peu près la même chose que les préprints
qui ont été pas publiés mais sont
accessibles en ligne
mais voilà si vous voulez savoir si je
vais parler de Mona Lady sachez que je
l'ai déjà fait et je vais préparer une
vidéo pour que pour faire un résumé en
gros de cette intervention que j'ai fait
avec Thomas Durand dans une vidéo à part
de ce paliere qui sortira dans quelques
semaines donc ne vous en faites pas et
pourquoi je j'aborde mon allée dit
maintenant bah c'est tout simplement
parce que il y a eu d'autres il y a eu
des news qui sont sortis pendant ces
vacances où on nous a ressorti une fois
de plus il faut réécrire toute
l'histoire de l'humanité
et si vous me connaissez vous savez que
c'est quelque chose que je déteste lire
parce que l'histoire de l'humanité elle
a jamais été réécrite ou en tout cas
elle a pas été réécrite depuis les
années 50 quand on a des bunks homme
depuis le down alors l'homme de pile
down oui il a fallu réécrire toute
l'histoire de l'Human l'humanité et
encore il y a un paquet de gens qui
n'était pas dupe du fait que l'homme de
pile down était un faux donc c'est pas
toute l'histoire de l'humanité qui a
fallu écrire mais en gros le dernier
événement de réécriture de l'histoire de
l'humanité c'était 1950
depuis on a rien réécrit on a raffiné ce
qu'on savait déjà on a mieux documenté
ce qu'on savait déjà on a rajouté des
choses à se conserver déjà mais rien n'a
été réécrit et pourtant on nous a sorti
des news donc omona Lady par exemple qui
réécrivent l'histoire de l'humanité et
cet article là en fait partie donc
publier dans le journal of human
evolution alors l'article en lui-même
évidemment ne prétend pas réécrire
l'histoire de l'humanité par contre
évidemment la façon dont il a été vendu
dans les médias ah ça ça l'histoire de
l'humanité on l'a réécrite ouh là là
donc il paraît si vous si vous lisez
dans les médias il paraît qu'on a
découvert une nouvelle espèce humaine et
ça réécrit complètement l'histoire de
l'humanité alors d'où ça vient bah ça
vient d'un fossile qui a été découvert
en Chine qui est daté si je ne m'abuse
d'à peu près 300 000 ans donc c'est gros
sommaire d'eau le l'origine d'Homo
sapiens en Afrique c'est à peu près le
même âge que l'époque à laquelle Homo
sapiens est apparu en Afrique et donc
voilà les restes qu'on a donc on a des
fragments de mâchoire des fragments donc
ce qu'il y a en jaune clair c'est ce qui
est réellement préservé le reste ça a
été reconstitué
plus ou moins plus ou moins comme on
pense que ça devait que ça devait être
quoi donc ça c'est ce qu'on en a
retrouvé et donc dans cet article au
lieu de dire que c'est Homo erectus
d'Asie puisque en Asie à cette époque là
normalement ce qu'on a c'est Homo
erectus l'Homo erectus asiatique étant
étant étant le vrai Homo erectus le mot
erectus africain il y a quand même
énormément de débats pour savoir si
c'est réellement un homo-actus mais
l'Homo erectus asiatique c'est le vrai
Homo erectus c'est pour ça que des fois
on appelle l'Homo erectus africain Homo
ergaster plutôt plutôt que de l'appeler
au moins erectus parce que l'Homo
erectus le vrai normalement c'est le mot
erectus asiatique et donc plutôt que de
le dater de Homo erectus plutôt que de
l'attribuer pardon à Homo erectus
asiatique sachant que Homo erectus
asiatique a pu s'éteindre très très
récemment jusqu'à 50000 ans donc 50 000
ans c'est très récent
ici il nous propose que c'est une
nouvelle espèce humaine sur la base de
plusieurs analyses morphométriques c'est
à dire basé sur des mesures
et selon eux donc il diffère de tous les
autres de toutes les autres espèces du
genre homo et enfin en tout cas du
playistoscène et je vois pas ça dans
leurs analyses là vous voyez par exemple
il y a un tableau c'est un analyse c'est
une analyse en composante principale
alors pour vous la faire courte il y a
des ronds et si ça tombe à l'extérieur
des ronds c'est différent si ça tombe à
l'intérieur des ronds enfin des là c'est
des polyèdres plutôt mais bref si ça
tombe à l'extérieur des polyèdres c'est
différent si ça tombe dans les polyèdres
c'est la même chose donc vous avez un
polyèdre pour le Néandertal pour les
PlayStation mini
pour Homo erectus etc etc et donc là
leur nouvelle mandibule enfin la
mandibule de leur nouvelle hominine elle
tombe avec Homo erectus là la mandibule
leur mandibule elle tombe alors il y a
un chevauchement de l'enfer donc ça
tombe dans plein de polyèdre différents
pareil vous avez un chevauchement entre
les playsthossen moderne human donc home
moderne et Homo erectus ici et puis ici
vous avez pareil un chevauchement de
polyèdre de la folie et ici vous avez un
chômagement de polyèdre de la folie
aussi donc à chaque fois leur mandibule
tombe dans un chevauchement de polyèdre
de la folie que ce soit la mandibule le
crâne les dents enfin bref tout ce qui
compare et donc au lieu de conclure que
on sait pas ce que c'est et puis voilà
ils vont quand même nous dire que c'est
une espèce d'hominée qui compte
connaissait pas je sais pas c'est si peu
concluant comme graphe si un étudiant
m'avait donné ça j'aurais dit
tu vas me nettoyer tes données un petit
peu là parce que on voit rien
on voit absolument rien de ce qui se
passe mais surtout ce qu'il conclut et
c'est là que c'est là encore une fois
que que j'ai un mouvement de recul c'est
que ils disent
ils disent quand même ce 7 hominé
soutient que l'apparition des caractères
morphologiques liés à Homo sapiens
modernes a pu avoir lieu en Asie il y a
300 000 ans c'est un article qui vous
coule en douceur
le modèle le modèle qu'on appelle multi
régional c'est et vous coule en douceur
le modèle multi-régional alors le modèle
multi régional si vous ne savez pas
c'est autrefois à une époque où on ne
savait pas où on ne savait pas on ne
connaissait pas la génétique notamment
on pensait que Homo sapiens était apparu
indépendamment en Afrique en Asie et en
Europe donc le ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui Homo sapiens en fait était
apparu à trois endroits différents
ce qui je ne vous le cacherai pas pour
les gens de l'époque expliquer pourquoi
les Caucasiens les Africains et les
Asiatiques
avaient l'air si différent c'est une
théorie qui est fortement engrainée
fortement enraciné dans un raciste
colonial dans un racisme colonial si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire c'est une
vieille théorie
qui essaye de survivre encore
aujourd'hui en grappillant si vous
voulez des petits événements là comme ça
ils vont les gens qui défendent encore
cette théorie aujourd'hui si vous voulez
ils vont grappiller des petits
événements d'hybridation par-ci par là
en disant mais vous voyez si si Homo
sapiens s'est hybridé avec Néandertal
c'est quand même un petit peu multi
régional oui mais cette portion de d'ADN
Néandertaliens pour les Européens et
Denisoviens pour les Asiatiques elle est
elle est minuscule et elle est
complètement écrasée par qui par quoi
par Homo sapiens d'Afrique
la génétique a cloué le cercueil de
cette théorie en montrant que les
crazantes diversité
d'Homo sapiens l'écrasante diversité
génétique d'Homo sapiens venait
d'Afrique ce qui soutient du coup bah
que le modèle Out of Africa le modèle de
la sortie d'Afrique Homo sapiens
originaire d'Afrique et est sorti
d'Afrique et là c'est hybridé très
localement avec des espèces qui
existaient déjà Néandertal et Denisova
le modèle Out of Africa le modèle de la
sortie d'Afrique c'est la génétique qui
le soutient de façon écrasante on a par
la même une origine d'Homo sapiens en
Afrique il y a 300.000 ans qui est à la
fois soutenu par les horloges
moléculaires et par les fossiles
puisqu'on a celui le l'homo sapiens
archaïque découvert en Afrique du Nord
au Maroc et donc là ce qu'ils essayent
de nous faire passer là en douce c'est
une petite quenelle là
elle a peut-être quenelle que celle de
passer du multi régionalisme ou en gros
non mais vous voyez on a des trucs qui
commencent à ressembler en Chine à peu
près à la même époque et et et bof en
fait pas tant que ça je sais pas là il
faudrait une analyse génétique si vous
voulez pour faire des conclusions pour
aller chercher une conclusion aussi
enfin qui contredit à ce point-là le
consensus actuel sur la sortie d'Homo
sapiens
consensus qui est majoritairement
soutenu par les analyses génétiques
analyse génétiques qui sont d'une
puissance phénoménale y aurait fallu
extraire de l'ADN là le seul moyen de
soutenir une conclusion du genre Homo
sapiens cette origine enfin il y a une
branche d'Homo sapiens qui est apparue
en Asie indépendamment de la branche
d'Homo sapiens d'Afrique il aurait fallu
au moins des analyses ADN et surtout il
y aurait fallu des analyses là
morphométrique comme ils ont fait là
qu'ils soient beaucoup plus enfin qui
place leur spécimens beaucoup plus au
sein de Homo sapiens modernes donc le
Homo sapiens moderne qui est ici par
exemple donc là par exemple il est super
éloigné d'Homo sapiens ce moderne et il
chevauchent avec plein d'autres espèces
qui ne sont pas homo sapiens modernes
idem ici Homo sapiens moderne il est là
leur truc il est ici
là vous avez Homo sapiens modernes là
leur truc il est en dehors enfin bref
d'où ça sort quoi d'où ça sort donc je
sais pas je comprends pas et donc une
nouvelle lignée humaine comme les médias
l'ont vendu certainement pas puisque ce
truc possède des caractères qu'on
retrouve dans plein d'autres lignes
humaines
et ancêtres d'Homo sapiens
d'Homo sapiens encore moins
encore moins mesdames et messieurs alors
là c'est un autre article dont on nous a
dit qu'il révolutionnait l'histoire de
l'origine de l'homme alors qu'en fait
non c'est cet article alors c'est quand
même un bon article je publier dans un
bon journal la communication biologie il
y a des grands noms dans le tas comme
David béguen par exemple donc c'est pas
un mauvais article mais c'est un article
dont la communication était pété ce qui
est bizarre pour un article qui est paru
dans biology communication mais c'est la
communication autour de cet articles
était pétée là on nous vendait une fois
de plus la réécriture de l'origine de
l'être humain et notamment vous avez
deviné si on a découvert un nouveau
grand singe en Turquie comme nous
l'indique le titre
on va nous sortir quoi bah évidemment
l'origine européenne de l'humanité dont
on nous a parlé dans les médias mais oui
alors le fossile très beau aucun
problème je suis d'accord c'est un grand
sage et c'est un très très beau fossile
de grand singe ils l'ont très très bien
étudié ils l'ont très très bien analysé
par contre voici les analyses
finogénétiques qu'ils ont trouvé et dans
leurs analyses phylogénétiques vous
voyez on a hardi piticus chimpanzé
gorille qui forme un Cloud je zoome un
peu Gorilla chimpanzé et les hominés ici
qui forment un Cloud
en dessous ici vous avez gorille
chimpanzé artipius qui forme un Cloud et
ici vous avez
art dpq sororine chimpanzegory qui forme
un clade donc ça veut dire que si toutes
les espèces africaines gorich chimpanzé
au mininet format cloud ensemble ça veut
dire que leur ancêtre en commun est
africain lui aussi
d'où sort cette origine européenne de
l'humanité dont on nous a parlé dans les
médias bah elle sort pas de cet article
en tout cas
je sais pas de quel article il parlait
mais il parlait pas de celui-là c'est
pas ça qu'ils disent
c'est pas ça que disent leur analyse
phylogénétique vous voyez là vous avez
homo enfin vous avez les hominés les
gorilles les chimpanzés et vous avez
leur nouvelle espèce donc Anna luvius
anadolulus qui est à part
et alors certes oui
l'ancêtre de des chimpanzés des gorilles
des humains et peut-être un immigrant
venu d'Asie l'ancêtre des grands singes
du coup des enfin des hominidés en
l'occurrence dans pas de tous les grands
singes mais de seulement des hominidés
c'est à dire humain chimpanzé gorilles 7
ancêtre là il a pu venir d'Asie et on
s'en doutait un peu parce que le groupe
frère de ces bêtes là c'est le enfin le
plus proche parent le plus proche cousin
de ces bêtes là c'est le c'est le rang
au temps elle aura autant il vit en Asie
et le plus proche cousin du groupe
orang-outan plus homididé africain c'est
ce sont les gibbons et ils vivent aussi
en Asie donc oui on se doute bien que le
l'ancêtre en commun de tous mondes là a
pu peut-être originaire de quelque part
en Eurasie peut-être même en Europe on
avait une belle grande diversité à la
fin du myocène en Europe on a une belle
et grande diversité
en Asie il y a plus d'une centaine
d'espèces qui vivent en Asie et en
Europe donc c'est pas impossible que le
l'ancêtre en commun de tous les grands
singes soit apparus en Eurasie c'est pas
impossible que l'ancêtre en commun des
chimpanzés humains gorille plus
orang-outan soit originaire d'Asie c'est
même pas complètement impossible que
l'ancêtre de chimpanzé humain égorie
donc l'ancêtre des hominidés africains
est migrée depuis l'Asie jusque
l'Afrique personne n'a jamais contredit
ça au contraire c'est le schéma qu'on a
depuis le début mais par contre humain
chimpanzé égorie eux ils sont
originaires d'Afrique la diversification
de ce cloud là il a eu lieu en Afrique
ça c'est certain et c'est pas cet
article là qui la remet en question je
sais pas pourquoi on a encore eu le
droit à
réécriture de toute lancé de de des
ancêtres de l'humanité en fait l'être
humain est originaire de d'Europe
[Musique]
ce n'est pas ce qu'il y a dans cet
article
mammifère toujours et cette fois on va
parler de l'extinction des grands
mammifères nord-américains les
smileodons les chameaux géants les les
mammouths aussi les mammouths les
mastodontes et les grands bisons géants
des plaines etc etc qui ont extinction
qui ont eu lieu il y a 10 000 ans
durant une ce qu'on appelle l'extinction
de la mégaphone du Dryas très jeune du
pré younger Trias donc le le la fade en
fait de la glaciation il y a 10000 ans
qui a accompagné l'extinction de toute
une faune très typique de l'Amérique du
Nord notamment les chevaux j'ai oublié
les chevaux mais évidemment les chevaux
qui étaient normalement qui était
originaire d'Amérique du Nord ce sont
éteint de l'Amérique du Nord
et les fameuses milodons les tigres
radins de sabre voyez elle a beaucoup
diversité qui se casse la gueule et boum
arrivée au Younger Dryas il y a 13000
ans à peu près bon j'ai dit 10 000 ans
mais c'est 13000 ans en réalité tout ça
cette diversité se casse la gueule et
disparaît alors cette extinction de la
faune de l'Âge de Glace littéralement
puisque c'est la c'est la faune que vous
voyez dans les films l'âge de glace
cette extinction dans ce nouvel article
nous propose qu'en fait elle est
accompagnée vous voyez d'une
recrudescence de de charbon c'est ce que
vous voyez là il y a 13000 ans le
charbon se sent plus péter on retrouve
du charbon dans tous les sens et ce
qu'il propose c'est qu'en fait c'est
l'arrivée de l'être humain alors
évidemment il y a des changements dans
la flore qui accompagnent les brûlis et
c'est brûlé on pense que c'est la
culture Clovis qui les a ramené avec
elle parce que vous voyez qu'il y a
quand même une coïncidence assez
foudroyante entre la culture Clovis
c'est à dire c'est une façon de tailler
les outils en fait la culture Clovis
donc c'est la
des humains qui évidemment l'amène avec
elle donc vous avez les humains de la
culture Clovis qui arrivent à Rancho
l'abréhat en Amérique du Nord et vous
avez l'extinction qui a lieu à peu près
en même temps et donc ce qui propose
c'est que ce sont les humains de la
culture Clovis qui est en pratiquant le
brûlis pour diverses raisons et
évidemment les extinction de la
mégaphone qui était associée bah au
plantes qui est dont dépendait c'est
pours animaux évidemment si toutes les
plantes crèvent les animaux les animaux
ne peuvent plus survivre les herbivores
notamment ne peuvent plus survivre s'il
y a plus d'herbivores il y a plus de
carnivores non plus
donc c'est ça qu'il propose alors du
coup si vous avez suivi ma mes vidéos
sur les extinctions de masse ça doit
vous rappeler quelque chose puisque je
vous avais dit c'est pas sûr sûr que les
êtres humains soient responsables de
l'extinction en Amérique du Nord parce
que maintenant on commence à avoir des
preuves que l'être humain est arrivé en
Amérique du Nord il y a 24000 ans mais
l'extinction en Amérique du Nord elle a
lieu autour de 10 000 enfin en
l'occurrence 13000 ans
avec la fin de la glaciation
et là en fait ce qui le scénario qui se
qui semble se profiler à l'horizon avec
cet article c'est qu'en fait à la fin de
la à la fin de la glaciation les humains
de la culture Clovis sont arrivés en
Amérique du Nord donc il y avait déjà
d'autres humains possiblesment sur place
qui avait eu un effet mineur sur le
sur la sur la biodiversité mais et
d'ailleurs un effet mineur dans le
registre fossile aussi parce qu'on en
trouve pas au des masses de reste mais
les humains de la culture Clovis qui
commencent à arriver à partir de 13000
ans eux ils ont foutu le bordel donc ils
ont ramené leurs petits outils de type
Clovis avec eux ils ont commencé à faire
du brûlis à pratiquer le brûlis
et du coup ça ça a pu provoquer par
contre le l'extinction de du prédrias on
sait ce qui est proposé dans cet article
que je vous invite à lire si vous voulez
en savoir plus on continue avec les
mammifères dans la revue Scientific
report c'est encore de la revue
prestigieuse c'est que de la revue
prestigieuse là c'est PNL science
scientific report national c'est que de
la revue prestigieuse ou en Chine on
nous annonce la découverte d'un
mammifère on est toujours avec les
mammifères un petit mammifère dont vous
voyez le squelette ici vous avez la tête
qui est là vous voyez ça vous voyez ça
ça ça ça son corps ici ça colonne
vertébrale ici il a une petite main là
vous voyez il y a des agrandissements
sur la main sur la tête sur la jambe ici
et ce mammifère en fait ce squelette de
mammifère date du Crétacé donc c'est un
petit mammifère de l'époque du Crétacé
qui s'appelle repénomamus qui est très
connu pour être le mammifère mangeur de
bébé dinosaure
à peu près 10 kg sur la balance 10 à 15
kg
c'est un des plus gros des petits
mammifères de l'époque voilà et donc là
il est en train de mordre un dinosaure
voilà il est il est préservé avec un
squelette de psytatosaurus que vous
reconnaissez bah si tacos ça veut dire
perroquet donc on le reconnait à son bec
de perroquet et donc là il se contentait
pas apparemment de que de bouffer les
bébés psy à cause de russe sauf aussi
nous suggère très fortement que il
s'attaquait aussi possiblement à des
psytes à cause de russe plus grands et
alors ce fossile est interprété par les
chercheurs qui ont écrit cet article
comme c'est en formé alors que répéter
nomamus était en train de se battre avec
le psittacosaurus alors il propose
diverses hypothèses pour expliquer
comment le l'enfouissement soudain a pu
préserver cette scène tout entière
à mon avis et là il y a tout un passage
sur sur la possibilité de de charognage
donc le scavenging que je vais hop voilà
c'est ici
c'est ici je l'ai mis en jaune déjà donc
il nous ils exclut en fait la
possibilité de charognage sur à mon avis
des choses qui sont pas hyper
convaincantes donc notamment le fait que
le mammifère est en train de mordre une
côte du dinosaure
semble exclure pour eux le charognage
alors ça bah justement le fait qu'il
soit en train de mordre une côte pour
moi ça veut surtout dire que la côte
était déjà décharnée quand il a mordu
dedans donc possiblement
que qu'il était déjà mort le petit à
cause de russe donc charognage donc ça
je trouve que c'est pas vraiment une
bonne raison de dire que c'était pas du
charognage il y a pas de trace dedans
alors l'absence de trace dedans ça veut
dire que l'animal qui a mordu l'autre
animal s'est attaqué uniquement à la
chair ça peut arriver pendant une
prédation mais ça arrive aussi
énormément pendant du charognage
l'absence de trace dedans ça veut juste
dire qu'il a pas renié les os c'est tout
et puis d'ailleurs tu as quand même le
machin en train de mordre dans la côte
quand même
et puis et puis il pense que en fait le
répéter nomamus enfin ce qu'ils disent
là dans cette phrase c'est qu'en gros le
répéter nomamus aurait pas grimpé sur le
psytacosor s'il l'avait charronnier il
se serait contenté de rester à côté en
fait il aurait pas eu à lui grimper
dessus ce qui me semble un peu léger
comme argument aussi je veux dire je
combien de fois vous avez vu un vautour
perché sur une carcasse par exemple
voilà bon bref donc je trouve que leurs
arguments pour exclure à un acte de
charognage sont un peu léger parce que
un acte de charognage étant donné la
taille du psittacosaurus par rapport au
Repenomamus serait quand même vachement
plus plausible
et
en plus étant donné la préservation en
fait c'est tellement plus simple de
préserver un acte de charognage qu'un
acte de prédation c'est un acte de
prédation ça dure ça dure pas longtemps
en fait un acte de prédation donc les
probabilités que ça finisse fossiliser
elle est infime alors qu'un acte de
charognage vous avez plusieurs
charognages vous avez probablement
plusieurs répétomus qui sont venus
bouffer sur la même carcasse et bon ben
les ça augmente quand même les
probabilités donc sur une longue sur la
longue intervalle de temps ça augmente
les probabilités du coup que l'un
d'entre eux finissent voilà qui est une
dune qui s'effondre sur eux ou je ne
sais quel événement
catastrophique qui font que ils sont
préservés comme ça donc oui je suis
d'accord que répéter nomamus mangeait ce
psytacosaure je suis pas d'accord qu'il
le mangeait pendant qu'il était vivant
je suis pas d'accord que c'est un acte
de prédation à mon avis c'est pas juste
la prédation est impossible pour moi
c'est juste les événements pour exclure
le chat enfin les éléments les preuves
propose ici pour exclure le charognage
sont juste pas assez robuste donc à mon
avis c'est plus probable qu'on soit face
à un acte de charognage comment le
répéter nomamus s'est retrouvé là bah il
y a plusieurs solutions comme j'ai dit
soit c'est un événement catastrophique
qui les a recouverts tous les deux en un
instant soit c'est possible aussi les
gaz de les gaz de décomposition de la
carcasse on tué le répéter nomamus voilà
quoi au moment où il a mordu là dans les
côtes il y a du gaz qui s'est échappé et
il s'est asphyxié avec
ils ont ils ont tous les deux séché là
comme ça au soleil dans cette position
là jusqu'à ce qu'il soit complètement
recouvert aussi
le problème c'est qu'il y a pas vraiment
de comme l'article est assez court il y
a pas vraiment de ta phonomie dans le
tas donc ils ont pas vraiment étudié
l'environnement de dépôt en tout cas pas
suffisamment pour qu'on puisse décider
donc voilà si vous avez vu des scènes de
combat épique quand tu as entre un
repénomamus et un psythagosaurus quelque
part sur les réseaux sociaux bah sachez
que ça vient de là et que c'était
probablement pas si épique que ça
un autre un autre truc qui a beaucoup
beaucoup circuler sur les réseaux
sociaux et dont on m'a beaucoup beaucoup
demandé de on m'a beaucoup demandé mon
avis c'est Pérou cétus Pérouse la
baleine géante du Pérou comme son nom
l'indique la baleine géante du Pérou
paru dans nightcher donc grosse revue
avec dans les auteurs Giovanni bianucci
une autorité en matière de cétologie de
paléo-sétologie et Olivier Lambert qu'on
a invité sur notre chaîne qui nous avait
parlé justement des baleines du Pérou
donc qu'il étudie
qu'il étudie et on le salue et on le
salue et donc père ou c'est tout ce que
c'est pérussectus pardon qu'est-ce que
c'est et ben c'est des grosses vertèbres
et des grosses et des grosses côtes
c'est voilà c'est une colonne vertébrale
on en a pas de crâne il y a beaucoup de
gens qui je sais pas pourquoi les les
gens sur Twitter ils s'énervent enfin
sur X il s'énerve pour rien en disant ah
le crâne de pérouseus il est trop petit
par rapport à la taille de son corps on
s'en fout il y a pas de crâne donc
faites ce que vous voulez avec le crâne
on s'en tape
bon bref on perd aussi il est il est
reconstitué comme étant une baleine
absolument gigantesque les estimations
de taille lui donne un poids proche de
celui d'une baleine bleue c'est ce que
vous voyez là lui donne un proie un
poids proche de celui d'une baleine
bleue et étant donné que c'est vertébres
sont boursouflés
ostéosclérose si vous avez vu mes
épisodes sur les baleines vous voyez que
l'os à l'intérieur des vertèbres il est
pas seulement épais les vertèbres elles
sont elles ont vraiment cette air
regardez ça c'est la vertèbre de Pérou
Cetus comparé à un basilosaurus parce
que ouais Pérou Cetus est un
basilosauridé je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi dans une seconde mais regardez
la vertèbre de Pérusse comparé à un
basilosaurus ou même comparer une
baleine bleue moderne elle est
boursouflée en fait cette vertèbre elle
est vraiment elle est vraiment très
bizarre elle est boursouflée de de
tissus pâquisostatique enfin pas qui
ostéosclérotique c'est à dire hyper
dense vous voyez qu'il y a aucun espace
entre les fibres là
à l'intérieur de l'os donc c'est donc
c'est c'est un animal qui était presque
aussi gros qu'une baleine bleue à en
juger par la taille de ses vertèbres
voyez que la vertèbres de Pérou Cetus a
pas grand chose à envier niveau
dimensions à celle d'une baleine bleue
donc c'est un animal qui niveau
dimensions deux verres ressembler à une
baleine bleue et qui niveau poids devait
légaler voir le surpasser étant donné la
densité de son squelette donc on est sur
du 200 tonnes bien tapés du 100 150 200
tonnes bien taper
et c'est un basilosauridé donc un proche
parent de basilosaurus pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont retrouvé cet osla qui est un
os du bassin et cette os du bassin
les gros les grosses baleines avec un
tout petit bassin c'est les basilosaures
idées donc ça il y a pas trop de il y a
pas trop de doute sur l'identité
basilosorienne de cette animal les côtes
aussi ressemblent beaucoup à un autre
un autre basilosaure idée qui s'appelle
pakistietus alors je précise pas qui
c'estus ch pas pakistatus avec un K il y
a pas qui c'est qui ça avec un K c'est
l'ancêtre des baleines celui qui a
quatre pattes et qui vivait en
indo-pakistan il y a 48 millions
d'années pas chie septus si vous voulez
le prononcer de façon non ambiguë pas
chie septus c'est par contre c'est un
basilosaure idée qui a vécu plus proche
des 30 millions d'années et des 30-35
millions d'années
ouais plutôt 35 35 40 millions d'années
même plutôt donc à 35 40 millions
d'années on n'a pas chi-sétus qui est
effectivement un basilosauridé ou très
proche parent des basilosaures aidés
dont les côtes sont exactement les mêmes
que ce que vous voyez là en fait pareil
très boursouflé très pâquisostatique
d'où son nom pas chi c'est US Paquis
comme pakistéphalosor l'épaisseur alors
que pakistatus du Pakistan c'est parce
qu'il a été trouvé au Pakistan c'est
pour ça que ça s'écrit avec un cas donc
il y a pas chietus la baleine épaisse
pas qui sait tous la baleine du Pakistan
voyez c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
mais on va s'y retrouver bon bref
l'identité à basilosauridé même si on a
que des vertèbres des côtés du bassin
c'est bon c'est soutenu le bassin c'est
celui d'un basilosauridé le les côtes
sont celles d'un très proche de
pachycétus
et donc oui on a cet animal qui serait
du coup
similaire en poids et en dimension à une
baleine bleue donc possiblement appelé
la dernière fois on avait eu les plus
gros animaux vivants sur Terre dans le
dernier Paléo news les saropodes
explique dont ils avaient sorti des
estimations de masse à 200 tonnes des
machins qui vivaient sur terre il y a
200 tonnes bon là on a au moins un vrai
une vraie plausibilité contrairement au
seropote de 200 tonnes on se demande
quand même comment ils auraient pu
fonctionner sur la terre ferme là au
moins dans l'eau à 200 tonnes on sait
que ça marche on a les baleines bleues
donc maintenant là ils estiment même
regarder 300 tonnes 300 presque 350
tonnes et il y a plusieurs tonnes déjà
de vertèbres enfin il y a plusieurs
tonnes d'os si vous te considérez le
poids de ces vertèbres là ça a dû être
un effort mais absolument titané ce que
pour les sortir du sol c'est comme vous
voyez la dimension des machins c'est
juste de la folie furieuse regardez
c'est quasiment la moitié de la taille
d'un homme les plus hautes vertèbres de
encore faut quasiment la moitié la
taille d'un être humain c'est ouais elle
est peut-être 50 cm de haut 50 70 cm de
haut ça doit peser une tonne une tonne
par vertèbre quoi donc voilà ce qui
amène pérouseus tout en haut de la
variation en termes de taille corporelle
chez les chez les animaux chez les
mammifères même pas que les mammifères
puisqu'ils ont inclus les dinosaures
sans aucun problème dans le tas et donc
ça suggère que déjà à partir si vous
avez encore une fois suivi mon cours sur
les cétacés je vous avais dit les
cétacés commencent à devenir géant les
mysticettes notamment les mysticettes
donc les baleines à fanons commencent à
devenir géantes seulement à partir du
playstosène après l'extinction de
mégalodon bon bah là
donc tout se passe comme si mégalodon
agissait comme un plafond de verre sur
la taille des mysticettes et une fois
qu'il a disparu pour elle devient géante
bon bah semblerait-il que avant
mégalodon il y a 40 millions d'années il
y a 35 40 millions d'années avant
mégalodon les baleines apparemment
faisaient déjà dans le gigantisme donc
ça ce qui d'ailleurs va assez bien avec
l'idée que une fois que mégalodon est
apparu en fait ça a vraiment placé un
plafond de verre sur la taille des
cétacés parce que là ce basilosauridé il
vivait il vivait il y a très longtemps
avant l'origine de autobus mégalodon
maintenant juste mon petit point
scepticisme cette morphologie de
vertèbre ça fait quand même sérieusement
penser à de la pathologie alors dans
l'article ils exclut la pathologie pour
plusieurs raisons que je trouve tout à
fait valide à savoir qu'ils ont tous une
colonne vertébrale et que toutes les
vertèbres sont pas qui ostentiques
exactement de la même manière donc elles
sont toutes boursouflées exactement de
la même manière ce qui dans une
pathologie normalement ne devrait pas
arriver
et surtout c'est la symétrie des
vertèbres toutes les vertèbres sont
boursouflées mais elles sont toutes
parfaitement symétriques alors qu'encore
une fois dans une pathologie on s'attend
pas à ce qu'elle soit boursouflée enfin
on s'attend pas à ce que c'est
boursouflures soit symétrique
mais personnellement
et encore une fois avec du respect pour
les auteurs etc je serai convaincu que
c'est que Pérou cétus n'est pas un n'est
pas un basilosauridé extra pathologique
quand on aura un second spécimen pour
l'instant on en a qu'un on a qu'un seul
spécimen donc la pathologie n'est pas
exclue je suis le premier à dire on peut
pas faire faire l'hypothèse que le seul
et unique individu qu'on a retrouvé dans
le registre fossile et pathologique
c'est pas une hypothèse raisonnable je
suis le premier à le dire et je suis
d'accord avec moi-même la raison pour
laquelle on peut pas faire l'hypothèse
que le seul et unique individu du
registre fossile et pathologique c'est
parce que l'hypothèse de base c'est que
ce qui a été préservé dans le registre
fossile c'est ce qui était le plus
commun et les individus les individus
pathologiques surtout des grands adultes
comme ce comme ce Pérou Cetus ces
individus pathologiques qui vivent
jusqu'à un âge très avancé c'est
définitivement pas ce qu'on a de plus
commun
dans le monde actuel les individus
pathologiques ils meurent très jeunes et
point barre donc là ça ça a très peu de
probabilité d'être une pathologie mais
personnellement d'un point de vue
totalement personnel je serai convaincu
que ce Pérou cétus n'est pas
pathologique quand on aura un second
individu donc je veux pas faire de
l'anticence il y a un moyen très facile
de montrer que j'ai tort mais c'est vrai
que là j'ai quand même ce petit touche
de scepticisme en me disant ça ressemble
quand même vachement à la maladie
osseuse de Paget alors c'est une maladie
des êtres humains donc ça s'applique pas
c'est assez mais du coup est-ce qu'il y
aurait pas un équivalent c'est assez un
qui est un équivalent s'est assez a de
la maladie osseuse de Paget qui se
serait manifestée chez ses balises
oridés rendant pérusétus bizarroïde
parce que les pachies c'est tous ils
ancêtres ils ont certes des côtes
boursouflées comme ça mais ils ont pas
des vertèbres boursouflé comme ça
les pachisétus et quand vous regardez le
canal neural de ce pachissetus elle est
quand même il est quand même vachement
écrasé donc ça je me demande comment
c'était fonctionnel en fait c'est
surtout ça mon truc comment est-ce que
c'était fonctionnel quoi je vous remets
la comparaison juste avec le la vertèbre
normal d'un
basilosauridé et d'un c'est assez
moderne c'est quand même c'est quand
même ouf quoi cette morphologie et
d'ailleurs cette ce canal neural très
écrasé c'est aussi un truc qu'on trouve
parmi les symptômes de la maladie de
pager donc je vous mets une petite image
là je vous la mets juste à côté pouf de
ce canal neural là juste ici comme ça
vous pouvez le voir
donc oui je donc oui très intéressantes
découvertes très intéressante qui remet
pas mal de choses en question sur ce
qu'on croyait savoir de l'évolution des
cétacés notamment sur l'évolution du
gigantisme chez les cétacé qui serait
qui aurait eu lieu beaucoup beaucoup
plus tôt que prévu ça sent la pathologie
même si j'ai probablement tort de le
penser mais
je ouais j'attends le deuxième j'attends
le deuxième spécimen le deuxième
spécimen me convaincra alors on revient
à la revenue Piana s PNAS avec et puis
on reste sur de l'aquatique avec
mégalodon évoqué du coup avec Pérouse
etus
mégalodon donc le grand requin le requin
géant du milieu scène et du Pliocène
requin géant qui dans ce nouvel article
nous dit-on aurait été endothermique
c'est-à-dire que ça aurait été un requin
à sang chaud alors faut savoir que le
c'est pas si étonnant que ça d'avoir un
requin géant à sang chaud la première
raison c'est que bah les animaux géants
ont tendance à avoir le sang juste parce
qu'ils sont géants c'est ce qu'on
appelle la gigantesothermie et aussi
parce que les parce que le requin blanc
par exemple il a ce qu'on appelle de la
régional endothermie c'est-à-dire que il
y a certaines parties de son corps dans
qu'il arrive à réchauffer par lui-même
l'endothermie étant défini par le fait
que on arrive à réchauffer son corps par
soi-même on n'a pas besoin des rayons du
soleil par exemple ou d'un volcan par
exemple dans les fumeurs noirs j'entends
pas les il y a pas d'animaux qui encu
dans les volcans pour se réchauffer mais
dans les fumeurs noirs il y a des il y a
des invertébrés qui ont le sang chaud
pourquoi bah parce que ils vivent à côté
d'un volcan donc c'est pas c'est pas ça
qui c'est pas eux-mêmes qui génère leur
propre chaleur donc l'endothermie c'est
la capacité de générer sa propre chaleur
le requin blanc le fait de façon
localisée dans son corps et donc là ce
qu'on nous propose c'est que mégalodon
le faisait dans tout son corps alors
c'est basé sur des analyses isotopiques
donc de la géochimie la géochimie
notamment de l'oxygène
la géochimie c'est la chimie osseuse la
chimie de ce qui est préservé dans alors
en l'occurrence c'est pas osseux c'est
dans les dents là puisque les requins
sont cartilagineux donc on n'a pas de
d'os de requin donc on fait ce qu'on
fait avec ce qu'on a et ce qu'on a c'est
des dents et donc en regardant la
géochimie des dents de mégalodon en
regardant le taux le taux des isotopes
d'oxygène à l'intérieur et comparer avec
d'autres animaux aquatiques et bien ce
qu'il constate c'est que autobus donc le
mégalodon ici en rouge et plus proche
des baleines ici en marron en fait que
des autres poissons alors là par exemple
vous avez Carcharodon le requin blanc en
orange donc requin blanc orange
mégalodon rouge
baleine en marron et donc ici on a quand
même le l'autodus en Caroline du Nord
enfin les dents donc de mégalodon qui
viennent de Caroline du Nord d'Amérique
du Nord qui sont dans la moitié
supérieure de la variation de de du
requin blanc donc des températures qui
seraient supérieures à celles du requin
blanc et qui serait qui chevauchent avec
celle des mysticettes donc là ça c'est
en
ça c'est ça c'est ce qui donne en fait
en termes de d'isotopes mais ça
s'interprète de cette façon en matière
de température comme vous voyez là donc
ici les ectothermes en bleu ciel les
endothermes ici donc les baleines en
marron et le mégalodon en Caroline du
Nord qui est donc aurait quand même
serait quand même plus proche de la
condition des baleines que de la
condition des autres poissons requin
blanc inclus
bon sauf que quand on regarde tous les
graphes c'est pas si évident que ça
quand même là par exemple là par exemple
les mégalodons ils sont vachement plus
proches du requin blanc au Japon qu'ils
ne le sont de des baleines
idem ici en Californie les mégalodons
sont vachement plus proches des requins
blancs qui ne le sont des baleines même
s'ils sont distincts à chaque fois des
des ectothermes donc des animaux à sang
froid ici vous avez même pas de baleine
comme point de repère en Allemagne et à
Malte mais par contre et là vous avez
même pas un malt vous n'avez même pas de
mégalodon vous avez son ancêtre
choubuencis et qui là est proche est
proche d'autres des régionales en deux
termes donc comme le requin blanc là ce
qu'il défendent dans l'article c'est une
endothermie totale du corps et c'est pas
évident partout
donc on aura au moins une heure de
termes régionale mais ça comme je disais
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment
questionnable enfin c'est pas vraiment
remis en question que le mégalodon était
capable d'une endothermie régionale
puisque le requin blanc n'est capable et
qu'il est beaucoup plus petit et le
mégalodon bon de par son gigantisme on
s'attend ce qu'il soit au moins en
partie en terme mais c'est vrai que le
signal est pas si clair que ça à part en
Caroline du Nord ou vraiment là il se
distingue et du requin blanc et des
autres ectothermes c'est pas si distinct
que ça et au Japon il est même plus
éloigné des mysticettes qu'il ne l'est
des ectothermes donc
donc les conclusions elles sont elles
sont intéressantes les données sont très
intéressantes et on a effectivement
possiblement le mégalodon qui serait
donc un an de termes ce qui aurait des
implications notamment sur sa vitesse de
croisière la vitesse à laquelle il
nageait sa possibilité à faire des
attaques rapides sa possibilité son
endurance et ça aurait du coup il aurait
s'il est en deux termes en fait il
aurait plus chassé comme une orque que
comme un requin voilà si vous préférez
du moins il aurait été capable de
chasser plus comme une orque que comme
un requin mais c'est ça a plusieurs
implications du coup et d'ailleurs c'est
très bien explosé explorer dans
l'article suivant parce que l'article
suivant sorti à peu près en même temps
nous présente des écailles de mégalodon
alors les écailles qu'on appelle des
placoïdes chez les mégalodons qui sont
en fait non pas des écailles mais ce
sont des dents miniatures donc tous les
requins ont des dents miniatures ça a
été publié dans historical biologist
c'est tout à fait des Jits comme le
journal
et ces petites écailles attendez que je
vous les montre voilà elles sont là
alors vous avez un petit patch vous
voyez de peau qui est fossilisé il faut
savoir que la peau des requins fossilise
vachement mieux que lorsque justement
leur peau est couverte de petites dents
donc c'est vraiment des dents dans le
sens où il y a une pulpe une cavité
pulpaire et il y a de mailles et il y a
de la dentine donc c'est vraiment des
dents dans tout le sens du terme c'est
juste qu'elles sont pas dans la bouche
donc voilà vous sont présentés ici
c'est ces petites écailles alors il y a
plusieurs espèces là il y a pas que
mégalodon mais en gros ce qu'ils ont
calculé enfin ce qu'ils ont estimé c'est
que à partir de la morphologie des
écailles en fait on arrive à comprendre
comment le requin nage c'est à dire que
la
morphologie des écailles qui recouvre la
totalité du corps du requin va être
directement dépendant de sa stratégie de
chasse parce que les cas il va donner un
hydrodynamisme qui va être différent
selon que si vous avez un requin qui va
chasser par des en embuscade vous voyez
avec des attaques rapides mes courtes ou
bien un requin qui va nager lentement
et sur de longues distances quoi qu'il
va faire de la chasse de fond si vous
préférez donc il va y avoir plusieurs
stratégies de chasse chez les requins
qui vont chacun correspondre à une
morphologie des cailles différentes et
donc ce qu'ils ont déterminé
à partir de la morphologie des écailles
de mégalodon c'est sa vitesse de ces sa
vitesse de croisière en fait donc
autobus mégalodon avait une vitesse de
croisière d'après la morphologie de ces
écailles donc c'est notamment les cartes
man entre les crêtes qui a sur les
écailles
mégalodon devait avoir une vitesse de
croisière d'à peu près 2 km/h il a les
écailles il a les écailles en fait il y
a les crêtes sur les écailles de
mégalodon qui sont très écartés et ça
c'est plutôt ça correspond plutôt à un
requin relativement lent alors que les
requins relativement rapide comme par
exemple le requin blanc eux ils vont
avoir des écailles avec une augmentation
beaucoup plus réduite beaucoup enfin
avec une ornementation des crêtes qui
vont être beaucoup plus resserrées donc
beaucoup plus effilées meilleur
pénétration dans l'eau donc là on a une
vitesse de croiser enfin une vitesse
à 3,2 d'une vitesse de croisière à 3,2
km/h donc il y a des requins qui sont
plus rapides et quand ils sont plus
rapides ils ont les crêtes sur leurs
écailles qui sont beaucoup plus
resserrer donc c'est ça qu'on observe
chez les requins et ça permet d'estimer
la vitesse de mégalodon à 2 km/h ce qui
est plutôt lent ce qui est plutôt lent
et ce qui considérant le fait que
l'article précédent là nous dit qu'il
est endothermique donc il produisait sa
propre chaleur au moins de façon
régionale sinon son corps tout entier
par gigantesothermie et bien ça veut
dire que cette vitesse très lente
c'est l'endothermie en fait ce dont ils
font l'hypothèse en fait c'est que cette
vitesse de croisière lente en fait elle
est plutôt contre-intuitive par rapport
à l'andothermie et du coup cet
endothermie à quoi elle devait servir
chez le grand chez le grand mégalodon
bah ça devait être surtout digestif
voilà c'est la conclusion de ce
paragraphe ici
ça devait être une endothermie qui
devait l'aider à digérer en fait donc en
réchauffant
les intestins en fait tout le tube
digestif en réchauffant le tube digestif
on augmente son efficacité on augmente
l'extraction de la on augmente
l'extraction
de nutriments ce qui permet du coup
d'alimenter aussi un requin gigantesque
parce que le mégalodon c'est de la belle
bête quoi et surtout quand on est dans
macro prédateur quand on est une baleine
en gros une baleine et qu'on est
filtreur bon d'ailleurs je rappelle je
pointe que Pérou cet Hus n'était pas un
filtreur d'ailleurs donc c'était un
macrop prédateur aussi perdus en tout
cas les basilosauridés sont pas des
filtresurs pour autant qu'on sache donc
pair ou c'est tous devait être un macro
prédateur comme les orques et donc c'est
dur de nourrir une quantité de viande
pareil donc mégalodon s'il avait été en
deux termes aurait pu utiliser son
endothermie pour mieux digérer en tout
cas d'après eux ils l'utilisait pas pour
faire des pointes de vitesse
parce que ça sa vitesse de croisière
était très inférieure à celle de
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres requins
d'ailleurs vous voyez elle est quasiment
inférieure après ce que tous les autres
requins à part les requins filtreurs il
y a que les requins filtreur qui
réellement une vitesse de croisière très
très très très lente
donc voilà on a quand même deux articles
sortis
qaq qui nous qui nous donne de très très
bons indices concernant la biologie de
mégalodon et ça je trouve ça cool c'est
pas juste ah il est super gros il est
super fort non non c'est là on a de la
bonne science aussi qui peut être qui
peut être faite avec mégalodon et c'est
super intéressant toujours dans la mer
mais on va un petit peu plus loin dans
le temps et puis on s'éloigne aussi des
poissons cartilage pour aller voir nos
poissons sarcopterygiens les cellacantes
le cellacante le fameux fossile vivant
un article de scientifique report nous
dit non fermez là c'est pas un fossile
vivant regardez à quoi il ressemblait
montélacante du Trias voilà c'est en
somme c'est ça c'est c'est la quant il
nous vient du Trias de Suisse
et donc vous voyez de cette région là
dans tout dans le sud de la Suisse
presque à la frontière italienne et dans
le Trias de Suisse ils ont découvert ces
vacances qui ressemblait à peu près à ça
il nous le reconstruisent d'ailleurs
comme un animal récifal regardez comme
il est beau il est beau et donc ça
ressemble pas c'est la corne du tout et
si ça ressemble pas à ses lacante
typique du tout bah ça veut dire que les
cellacantes étaient très diversifiées et
que leur réputation de faux cils vivants
n'est pas du tout méritée et là en plus
ils ont même réussi à comparer les
changements qu'on voit dans certaines
lignées de ces vacances avec les
changements enfin les changements
morphologiques qu'on voit dans certaines
similiades c'est laquante ils les ont
comparé avec des changements génétiques
connus pour affecter la morphologie des
poissons et donc ils arrivent en fait à
reconstituer les gènes et comment ils
ont muté en fonction de la morphologie
de leur colacante et ça c'est
complètement de la folie et donc ça ça
suggère très bien le ce qui a fallu
comme mutation et donc évolution pour
que nos pas fossiles vivants évoluent
effectivement
et ça rappelle aussi d'ailleurs ce sont
des gènes ce sont des gènes Hedgehog
c'est à dire que ce sont des gènes
homéogènes des gènes architectes et ça
ça nous rappelle ce qu'on ne ce que vous
avez certainement appris ou pas et que
Stephen gegould avait dit un gros
changement morphologique ne nécessite
pas forcément une grosse mutation vous
pouvez avoir des changements
morphologiques gigantesques donc comme
ceux qui sont représentés ici en rouge
qui peuvent avoir des origines à
l'origine des mutations tout à fait
anodines tant que ces mutations touchent
des gènes architectes c'est-à-dire des
gènes qui qui sont des clés de voûte en
fait du développement de la morphologie
de l'animal donc une petite mutation
d'un jeune architecte peut donner pour
résultat de grands changements
morphologiques
donc ça c'est aussi un truc qu'il faut
s'enlever de la tête pour faire pour
faire des grands changements en
morphologiques faut forcément faire des
grosses mutations notamment auprès des
créationsnistes les créationsnistes
adorent faire ce raccourci alors qu'il
est complètement faux et qu'on le sait
depuis Stephen geigould c'est-à-dire
depuis les années 70 on reste au Trias
mais cette fois on passe à UPS qui est
un cousin des ictyosor un cousin des
étiosaure qui vivait au Trias en Chine
et cette upsucus alors c'est un animal
bien bien curieux qui a intrigué les
gens pendant très longtemps et un
nouveau crâne que vous voyez ici nous
indique que UPS avait vous voyez ça
c'est le crâne vu du dessus vous avez
les yeux ici et en fait vous avez ces
espèces de très long prémaxillaire à
l'avant du crâne qui ne se touche pas au
milieu et qui forme des sortes de
plateau à l'avant du crâne et ça chez
les baleines modernes ce sont les mêmes
plateaux prémaxillaire qui soutiennent
les fans donc là c'est UPS à gauche et
une baleine à droite et du coup si vous
avez certainement vu passer ça sur
Twitter ou n'importe où des
reconstitutions d'une espèce de reptile
géant qui a l'air de se nourrir comme
une baleine en fait en engourant comme
une baleine et bien figurez-vous que
cette upsucus voilà donc cousin des
idiots vous avez les idiosaures ici
upsucus là au tout début du Trias donc
il fait partie j'en avais parlé aussi
dans mes cours de ces trucs zarbis qui
ont évolué au Trias toutes ces fans
notamment de reptiles marins qui qui
sont apparus très très vite mais n'ont
pas réussi à se stabiliser parce que il
y a eu ré extinction à la fin du Trias
bon bah là
UPS c'est un très très bon exemple de ça
et donc une diversification
morphologique absolument incroyable
puisqu'on ne reverra pas ça et c'est ce
qui vous est suggéré dans ce tableau on
ne reverra pas ça avant BIM les les
mysticettes
et le quatrième siècle après
Jésus-Christ donc mon histoire ma
connaissance de l'histoire est-ce
qu'elle est mais à l'époque normalement
l'Angleterre était encore
sous-occupation romaine et donc dans une
cache dans laquelle des objets ont été
déposés par ces romains en fait il y
avait plusieurs objets dont 7 vertèbres
de plésium et donc c'est en faisant des
fouilles en fait dans ce citron romain
que les archéologues ont découvert cette
vertèbre de plaisir et ça ça veut dire
que les Romains pendant l'Antiquité
tardive
découvrez déjà des ossements et ça on en
a déjà parlé plein de fois c'est
notamment les travaux d'Adrienne mayor
qui ont montré que les Romains ont
découvert énormément d'ossements
notamment de promotions de mammouth
d'animaux de l'âge des glaces de l'Âge
de Glace notamment
et mais là cette vertèbre de plésiosaure
c'est la première fois d'après Adrienne
mayor avec qui j'ai pu discuter sur
Twitter c'est la première fois
que qu'on retrouve des restes de
l'époque romaine qui contiennent un
animal enfin le fossile d'un animal de
l'époque des dinosaures c'est pas un os
de dinosaure mais c'est quand même un os
qui date de l'époque des dinosaures et
ça ça ouvre des perspectives quand même
sur la la connaissance
de du registre paléontologique et
surtout la passion pour les fossiles
c'est c'est l'archéologie de la
paléontologie qu'on voit là si vous
voulez c'est la passion du fossile elle
est vieille elle est ancienne il y a des
gens qui se voilà là on est on est
plusieurs milliers d'années avant
marianning et pourtant on a de la
découverte de plésiosaures et moi je
trouve ça ouf je trouve ça absolument
complètement ouf
[Musique]
sur le maxillaire
donc c'est sa petite particularité à lui
qu'il partage avec certains autres
membres de sa famille qui s'appelle les
lagères petitd et alors dans une
nouvelle analyse philogénétique de ces
lages arpetidés on nous propose que
venetro Raptor est en fait un cousin des
térosores ce qui nous donnerait un petit
indice sur la provenance des petits
roses parce que les petits ressorts
l'origine des pérosaures c'est vraiment
un énorme problème on ne sait pas d'où
il sort vous voyez ils apparaissent au
milieu du Trias là et il y a aucune
ligne qui va plus loin que le milieu du
Trias et ils veulent déjà en disant déjà
le quatrième doigt qui est super long et
ils ont des ailes attachées dessus et
ils savent déjà voler et avant ça on n'a
rien on sait pas d'où ils sortent alors
d'où qu'il sorte les petits ressorts
peut-être
des lagères petit D et ça et ça
venetoraptor nous le suggère pourquoi
parce que quand vous regardez
vénitoraptor alors ça c'est un de ses
cousins la gerpette idée vous voyez sa
main elle est très typique de celle des
archosor c'est les doigts 1 2 et 3 qui
domine
le doigt 5 est réduit et le doigt 4
commence à se réduire donc chez les
dinosaures c'est ce que vous voyez les
dinosaures donc le 3 doigts aux mains
chez les crocodiles les ils ont quatre
doigts mais le quatrième doigt est plus
petit que le doigt numéro 3 donc c'est
très typique des archosants en fait
d'avoir une main dominée par le doigt du
milieu donc ils sont en voilà ils sont
ils montrent ils font un middle finger à
longueur de temps quoi donc bref la main
chez les archosorts typiquement est
dominé par le doigt du milieu sauf chez
les ptérosores chez qui c'est le doigt
numéro 4 donc l'auriculaire non
l'annulaire pardon l'annulaire qui est
le plus long et bien chez venez trop
Raptor venetror Raptor est le seul
archosaure à part les ptérosaure chez
qui le doit numéro 4 est le plus long
on voyait qu'il en manque des bouts
quand même
les morceaux de non préservés vous voyez
sont en marron mais enfin ils ont quand
même suffisamment de de morceaux pour
pouvoir dire que les phalanges étaient
plus longues que celles du doigt numéro
3 donc le doigt numéro 4 de vénétrer au
Raptor est plus long que le doigt numéro
3 et ça c'est un caractère qu'il est en
commun avec les petits ressorts alors
c'est beaucoup moins dramatiquement
gigantesque que le doigt numéro 4 des
ptérosols je suis d'accord ça fait quand
même ça donne quand même un sérieux
sérieux sérieuse indice sur l'origine
des ptérosols donc on se demande quand
même si avec ses lagères pétillés là on
serait pas en train de regarder le voilà
la première diversification des
ptérosols et donc c'est ce qui vous est
très subtilement représenté ici avec un
venez trop Raptor qui est reconstitué
avec du duvet exactement comme les
terres leçons mais on n'a aucune trace
de ça dans le fossile donc vous vous en
faites pas vous avez vous avez le droit
de le représenter comme vous voulez mais
on représente de fait arboricole et
couvert de duvet pour bien souligner
qu'en fait il est à la RAM il est
finalement prêt à s'élancer dans les
herbes voilà et à étendre ses ailes et à
devenir les petits ressorts du futur on
sort des vertébrés on va quand même on
va quand même parler un petit peu
d'invertébré dans ce paléoz hein bon
donc on va parler de dickinsonia qui est
un très très un très fameux très célèbre
fossile qu'on retrouve dans la faune
d'ediacarat Lydia Cariens c'est le c'est
le le petit sursaut de diversité avant
la faune de burgès faune de Burgess ou
contrairement à les acariens on va
retrouver des ancêtres de de grands
groupes qui existent encore aujourd'hui
alors que les diacariens ça a rien
laissé derrière bref
dickinsonia donc qui avait été découvert
en Inde pour la première fois dans un
article qui avait été publié en décembre
en fait en fait c'était pas indiqué une
Sonia voilà c'était c'était
la trace laissée au plafond par vous
voyez un nid d'abeille il y avait des
ruches il y avait des ruches au plafond
vous voyez de la grotte enfin de la
fleur manque aussi vous préférez et ces
ruches en tombant elles laissent
derrière des empreintes qui ressemblent
à ça et ses empreintes bah ça ressemble
quand même vachement dickinsonia mais en
réalité c'était pas dit Kin Sonia
c'était juste des voilà c'est très bien
ça ça ressemble vachement à dickinsonia
je suis d'accord vous pouvez aller voir
je vous mets une petite photo là de
dickinsonia juste pour vous puissiez
comparer mais ça ça ressemble quand même
vachement à dickinsonia mais en fait
quand on y regarde de plus près c'est
pas dit qu'il Sonia c'est juste les
résidus de la ruche laisser sur la roche
donc ça je vous en fais cadeau hein
c'est
c'est pas ça ça va certainement
ressortir dans la littérature
créationniste en mode et il nous manque
les paléontologues et tout ça non il est
pas c'est des paléontologues qui ont
montré que qu'il y a eu un une erreur et
c'était juste une bête erreur et c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave parce que la
paléontologie comme toutes les sciences
est auto corrective quand on fait des
erreurs on se on les répare nous-mêmes
et oui c'est les créationsnistes eux ne
découvrent rien c'est la différence
entre les paléontologues et les
créations les décréationnistes ne
découvrent rien rien du tout il y a rien
de nouveau qui est jamais sorti de la
tête d'un créationniste pour conclure un
article dans Nature évidemment
et dans cet article on va conclure sur
de la géologie de la pur géologie de
chez nous avec la découverte sur Mars
par un Rover
de fentes de dessiccation
et ça c'est une preuve géologique aussi
directe qu'elle puisse l'être qui a eu
de l'eau liquide sur Mars et en
l'occurrence là il la date de 3,6 à 3,8
milliards d'années c'est-à-dire qu'il y
avait de l'eau sur Mars à peu près à la
même époque où la vie est apparue sur
terre j'avais fait toute une vidéo sur
la possibilité de l'existence de
stromatolite enfin de structure proche
des stromatolites sur Mars et de tapis
de possible tapis bactérien et donc là
je crois pas qu'il fasse l'hypothèse que
un tapis bactérien soit impliqué dans la
préservation de ces de ces formes de
d'excitation mais sur terre sur terre il
faut des tapis bactériens en fait pour
que ce genre d'empreinte puisse se
fossiliser tout simplement parce que
sinon l'érosion va aller virer bon sur
Mars le fait est que l'érosion est
beaucoup moins de
parce que du coup l'atmosphère est
tellement fine en fait qui est quasiment
pas d'érosion sur Mars et puis s'il y a
plus d'autres façons il y a plus
d'érosion donc enfin le principal
facteur d'érosion est parti donc il y a
pas forcément besoin de tapis bactérien
pour préserver ses formes de
dessiccation sur Mars mais si en plus
des analyses futures pouvaient dire
qu'il y a eu un tapis bactérien qui a
aidé à la préservation de ses fentes de
dessiccation ce serait quand même de la
folie furieuse donc voilà le mais là je
généralement je parle pas trop de des
trucs voilà on a encore découvert de
l'eau sur Mars mais super mais ça c'est
quand même de la belle géologie quoi
c'est ça qui m'a plu quand je l'ai vu
sur wow c'est la preuve géologique aussi
claire qu'elle puisse l'être qui a eu de
l'eau ici quoi celle là c'est c'est
visuel quoi c'est hyper visuel
voilà c'était Paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'ancien et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]